hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video i would
like to talk to you about the high
dollar which is a cryptocurrency that i
really believe in and something is
happening there so let's get into it
[Music]
all right yeah so let me just remind you
uh what is the high dollar it's a
cryptocurrency uh in decentralized
finance that has been created by uh some
people from hong kong i know some of
them personally it's a big project i
really do believe in this long-term
project i started to talk about this
cryptocurrency when it was trading
around 30 cents it is right now at 90
cents and the reason why i'm talking
about it right now is because i have a
feeling that it's gonna go maybe too too
quickly the reason behind is first when
you have a look at the chart so you can
go on coin market cap you can find the
high dollar just here in the search bar
and when you go here guys and you check
the chart you can see we have a breakout
that happened a few days ago after a
strong dip so like i said i know some
people working there and i have a
feeling that this move is gonna keep
going higher
so how can you get high dollars the best
way to get it is for free just by
clicking on the link in the description
of this video you can subscribe and just
receive a free high dollar every day by
claiming it through whatsapp or telegram
this is what i've personally been doing
and it's a referral system so thanks to
you guys i reached quite a decent amount
of high dollars
right now the reason why i'm telling you
these guys is because something is
happening right now so if you want to
get in there are many ways so i'm going
to show you what is the best way to
trade high dollar first and then i'm
going to explain why i personally
believe in this project so the first way
you go on high.com you just click on go
to pancake swap you can trade it on uni
swap but the spread is big
you can see on coin market cap i don't
remember where it is yes you can see
that 98 percent of the volume is trading
on pancake swap so this is the place you
want to be trading this token i have
checked the bid offer spread is around
five percent so if you buy now and you
unwind at for example two you just gonna
lose basically five percent seven
percent uh in the bit of a spread uh so
it's pretty tight uh for this this kind
of cryptocurrency that is not listed yet
this is one of the reason it might go
much higher because it's not listed on
any exchange at the moment so once again
you click on go to pancake swap then you
need to collect connect your metamask
wallet guys and you need to find the
high dollar share so if you don't find
it by just typing high dollar
here you can copy paste the key
from coin market cap so this key you
just copy paste this key you bring it
here and then you're gonna find the
you're gonna find the high dollar on
pancake swap so this is one way to do it
and you can buy and sell but once again
there is a fee that is around seven
percent in the transaction so this is
more um i would say maybe to keep for
the longer term and i personally do
believe uh in the long term of this uh
token because once again i know people
who are doing this and i know what
they're targeting they're targeting you
know a real groove and they have some
expectations coming in you know one year
two years they want to get connected
with banks they really want people to
use their networks they want to make the
coins available to pay in the
restaurants in some hotels some other
activities whatever
so i think it's a nice project and my
friend just sent me you know the reasons
why he personally do believe in this
project so my friend is now as a
director of the marketing strategy there
and i also know a guy that is involved
in the management so they gave me some
information that is uh that i can tell
you guys they told me that it's okay to
tell so the first information is that
it's gonna get listed maybe soon on some
big exchange so of course this can have
a major impact on the price action there
is also as we can see here guys the
number of users is just
growing very quickly we have right now
1.6 million users it's been a few months
only that this token has been created so
it's going quite fast it's actually very
fast so the more users the more value
the token will have and yeah there is
one more news he told me that there
gonna be some significant announcements
relating to the high protocol as well as
launching a gaming platform to support
game fi and marketplace for its large
membership base all right so those are
the three information that i'm giving
you that are public information but once
again i get them maybe a bit earlier
it's not listed yet and it might be
listed soon they're gonna get into the
gaming industry as well uh using their
tokens and it's a very long term project
so for all those reasons i do believe
that this uh and technically we have
here like i showed you guys some kind of
a breakout around here you i don't have
a tool here to make the trend line but
if i would you can see that here we have
a breakout around 0.75 and since then we
are going higher so i think the momentum
will keep happening here uh so once
again if you are not involved in this
cryptocurrency yet i think it's a very
good long-term investment personally i
am involved and if you want you can also
get it at the cheaper price you can get
it at a discounted price but you need to
keep it on the website so to do that uh
you just go on high.com and you click on
high dollars here
okay buy high dollars all right so
whenever you do that it's gonna ask you
to get connected so i'm personally
connected right now so i'm gonna enable
this later and you can see i have right
now so 10 000 equivalent usd so it's not
big but it's you know
it's a decent position and you can
get the high dollars so you click here
buy high
and you see i can have a discounted
price i can get it for 35 cents if i
want right now
but i need to stake it for four years
and i also can have it at 60 cents if i
only stake it for one year so this is
something that i personally think is a
good investment i will of course try to
get advantage of this uh better prices
and once again guys i would like to
share this with you because i personally
do believe in this project and i think
it's a nice one so i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget guys to click on the sub like and
bell button so you're going to be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys